MIKE MAHEMOFF: Yes, so as
Sam said, I'm Mike.
Right now, I'm actually working
on Player FM, which is
very much around audio.
So audio is really the aspect
of media that's been most
interesting to me.
And as well as that, it is
actually a responsive web app.
So images for any web app is
going to be important.
And I think something that I
focus a lot on is the concept
of developer experience, and
looking at developers as users
as well, and basically
understanding what it's like
for a developer to perform
any particular task.
And what are the complications
they're having?
For me, as just working
as a one man band, my
time is very valuable.
And so a lot of this too
is not just about pure
functionality--
what sort of media capabilities
have we got?
But it's also about making it
really straightforward for
developers to do it without
having to spend too much time.
I know most of my images
are kind of
responsive to the user.
They look responsive, but
they're loading way too much
data, just because I don't
have the time to do
it the right way.
So those are the kinds of things
I hope we can focus on
as well today.
So do you want to go around,
and we'll just really
briefly-- we're pretty
short on time.
So just say who you are
and what you do.
JUSTIN UBERTI: Hi, I'm
Justin Uberti.
I'm a tech lead for Chrome.
And I am one of the founders
of WebRTC.
JASON GRIGSBY: Hi, I'm
Jason Grigsby.
I'm one of the co-founders
of Cloud Four.
And I've spent way too
much time looking
at responsive images.
JOHN MELLOR: Hi, I'm
John Mellor.
I work for Chrome for
Android in London.
I've got view ports and worked
on those kinds of things.
And I like to work on
images as well.
ANDRE BEHRENS: My name
is Andre Behrens.
I work for the "New York Times"
on the Chrome app.
And my job title is developer
advocate.
My real title is troublemaker.
And I have complained
to the Chrome
team a lot about images.
MIKE MAHEMOFF: So I thought
actually Andre might be a good
person to start.
Because you've got some
impressively scary stats about
how many images you have to deal
with at "New York Times."
Do you want to talk a little bit
about the challenges you
face and how you actually
deal with them?
ANDRE BEHRENS: The challenge we
face is that we publish 300
articles every day--
300, 300 articles every day.
And if you're making something
that's supposed to show the
whole "New York Times," that
means you have to show 300.
So to give an example of how
awful that is, I used to have
a section that came from our
"Times" wire feed that would
do the last 24 hours
of articles.
And it crashed the app,
so I took it out.
It just couldn't load
that much stuff.
And we like to show these nice,
big, beautiful images
that we pay people a lot of
money to put up to take-- and
that they put their lives
on the line to get
a lot of the times.
And those big, beautiful images
in it, in order to fit
into our apps, the way we used
to do it on the website was
the whole thing was structured
kind of around the images.
This is how big it can be,
because this is how
big the image is.
And so we would just have people
manually cutting them
whenever they could, pulling
from this giant database.
And now we're trying to move
into a more fluid style, both
on our website and in
some of our apps.
And a big reckoning call was
when the iPad came out.
And they were saying, well, we
don't want to have to look.
Because we would have images
for certain things in
different sizes.
They didn't fit together.
So we made people put
in the big ones.
So now you're doing a
thing where you're
resizing all your images--
big performance problem.
And then, retina stuff
came out, and these
stupid pixels came out.
And now the main image we use--
that's the main one to
work with-- is called jumbo.
And that's 1024 by 768, which is
full screen on an old iPad.
Then, the retinas came out, so
we had to double the size.
So they are 2048 on a side.
And they take a long
time to download.
time to render.
And they affect everything
else.
And if you are casually resizing
them, which a lot of
our developers will be inclined
to do in this sort of
lazy way, it slows
everything down.
And it doesn't make sense why
it's taking so long to load.
And it's just a problem.
MIKE MAHEMOFF: And do you have
any particular techniques that
you're using to pick
up on that?
ANDRE BEHRENS: We are
considering a fairly insane
one for the Chrome app.
We actually built an enormous
Amazon-backed socket connected
system that has multiple
balancing layers.
And I raised the crazy idea,
well, why don't we just draw
every image at every
pixel size--
1024, 1023, 1022, 1021, 1020.
And I went to the guys, and I
said, why don't we do it?
And they were like,
storage is cheap.
So we might try that--
no promises.
But I don't think that's really
realistic for the
average web developer.
MIKE MAHEMOFF: Yeah, well it
sort of leads to responsive
images-- one sec.
You can come up and ask a
question after, actually, if
you want to come up now.
ROB: We're doing that now.
MIKE MAHEMOFF: Oh, OK, you're
already doing that technique
of drawing images at
every dimension.
ROB: Whatever's requested.
MIKE MAHEMOFF: Whatever's
requested, you'll just pull it
out and probably cache
it on demand, right?
Yeah, OK, and who are you?
Can you say?
ROB: I'm sorry.
Rob from "Times."
MIKE MAHEMOFF: Rob from
"Financial Times," OK, so it
sort of leads to responsive
images, which you guys are
working on pretty closely.
Do either of you want
to comment?
JOHN MELLOR: I'll start by
making a distinction.
There's fixed width images, like
maybe a logo or an icon,
where the main problem is
resolution switching.
You want to load your
retina image or
your non-retina image.
And it's not just 1x and 2x.
So you've got more ones.
But there's actually
a simpler problem.
And the really hard problem
tends to be where flexible
width images were.
You want the image to be--
say its width 100% is CSS.
It needs to match the size of
the page for whatever device
you're loading it on.
And doing [INAUDIBLE]
mark-up is really
tricky at the moment.
JASON GRIGSBY: Yeah, so the way
that I tend to think about
it is, we've got a big conflict
between what the
browser wants, which is to be
able to start requesting
assets as soon as it can
recognize the assets in the
document, versus what people
want to do in responsive
design, which is to have the
elements on the page, and
particular images, basically
size based on the element that
it actually is, like the size
of the element in the page.
And to me, it's sort of akin to
when I've gone on vacations
with members of our family who
want to script every part of
the vacation.
And then, you've got other
people who don't want to plan
ahead at all.
And those are incredibly
tense vacations.
And that's what's going on
from sort of an imaging
perspective, where we've got
this conflict between what
responsive design people
generally want to do, which is
to wait until the layout is
determined by the viewport
size and other characteristics
of the device, and what the
browser wants to do, which is
to start selecting assets as
soon as it can.
JUSTIN UBERTI: One of the things
I think is interesting
is that for a long time, we were
sort of told that JPEG
was fine, that JPEG was
a standard algorithm.
We should all use that.
If you save 20%, it doesn't
really matter.
Now, with retina size images,
saving 20 or 30% is actually
translating into real user
experience benefit.
And so with WebP, where we can
get an additional 30, 40%
compression on images, that
makes a real difference in
terms of page mode when the
actual vast majority of the
bytes is coming from images.
MIKE MAHEMOFF: OK, but what
are the actual practical
techniques you're seeing, for
instance, Jason, in terms of--
are people using JavaScript?
Are people finding it just
doesn't work in practice?
JASON GRIGSBY: So I think the
first answer is that there
isn't a solution that isn't
sort of a hack, right?
What people are doing right
now is picking which
compromise they want to use.
So what we've been
advising people--
and I just recently consulted
a company that has over
800,000 images.
And they've got a very
similar process.
Images are coming
in all the time.
They're dealing with
this stuff.
And essentially, what we're
looking at is, one, they've
been hand cutting everything.
They're moving to a system that
will automate resizing on
the server.
And then, they're actually
using picture fills.
So they're using the JavaScript
library to make
decisions like what the picture
element would do if
the picture element
were to come out.
But they're centralizing that
into a single function so that
when it changes, whatever the
new format will be, whatever
the standard ends up
being, they can
quickly change that out.
Because it's clear that whatever
you implement now
will be deprecated.
We just don't know what
it's going to be
deprecated in favor of.
JOHN MELLOR: So it's a balance
between quality, performance,
and simplicity.
There aren't really any simple
approaches at the moment for
flexible width images.
So that's out, anyway.
But then, you want the
images to load fast.
And we also want to
load high quality.
And it's kind of a fundamental
conflict between these.
So in terms of techniques with
flexible width images, there's
JavaScript.
But JavaScript techniques tend
to load images only when the
DOM is fully loaded, a
DOMContentLoaded event.
And by this point, typically
about a third of the page's
content, including all the
resources, has already
finished downloading.
And the page would be ready to
display if it weren't for the
images, which is holding
everything back.
And so it's really too
late to be requesting
images at that point.
And the images need to be
somehow in the markup before
that happens.
MIKE MAHEMOFF: So what's
the solution?
It sounds almost like
it can't be solved.
JOHN MELLOR: Yeah, so there
are some server-side
solutions, and you can do device
detection, which isn't
great, because device
databases suck.
You can do things like setting
cookies or changing the base
href for your page at the
top of your head.
And then, any images requested
relative URL will be served
from an appropriate directory
in your server.
And you'll set up base href
based on the screen width and
the device pixel ratio,
for example.
So there are techniques
you can use today
that sort of work.
But yeah, we need better
solutions in the future.
MIKE MAHEMOFF: And what's
happening with that, the
picture element?
Is that something that's
realistically going to be
coming out this year,
for instance?
JOHN MELLOR: The picture
element's under
discussion a lot.
There's [INAUDIBLE]
you can go read.
I think it doesn't seem
like it at the moment.
And everyone's still hashing
out use cases
for it, and so on.
It also doesn't really solve
this problem directly.
Because you still get this
fundamental conflict--
well, not conflict.
But to actually put a picture
element that will load the
right image on various different
devices or different
resolutions, you need 10
different rules for every
single image, like all the
widths times all the device
pixel ratios.
And it's really hard
to actually--
well, it is not a great
solution [INAUDIBLE].
MIKE MAHEMOFF: OK, does anyone
else want to comment about the
whole issue of images
before we move on to
WebRTC, and so on?
Or any questions, by
the way, feel free.
ANDRE BEHRENS: Just to add on,
the same problem with the
performance, the developers are
not used to dealing with
this at all.
Because literally the easiest
thing in the world to do in a
web page, is put an image
referred to a URL and have it
show up, and you do nothing.
And now I'm coming to you--
OK, so we need about
30 different sizes.
And we have these different
stop points in
our responsive design.
We're going to put
these in here.
And you have to think about
putting this here.
And maybe we're changing
formats.
And nobody on our team has ever
thought about this in
their life ever until
right now.
They have no experience
with it.
JASON GRIGSBY: I think one
of the things that--
so I've spent a lot of time
working with the responsive
images community group and
talking about the different
use cases, whether it's the art
direction use case or the
resolution switching use case.
And all of this has been in an
effort to sort of create that
balance between what the
preparser wants and what
responsive designers want.
And I was talking yesterday
about how, increasingly, I'm
beginning to wonder if it is
solvable, or if we're going to
end up in a situation where
we have to choose
between one or the other.
And so Estelle has this
really, really amazing
technique using SVG where you
can do media queries inside
SVG, and SVG also does raster.
And so basically, you can have
an SVG image that is basically
an image bundle that
is responsive.
SVG isn't supported across--
it isn't on Android 2.3.
And there are some other sort
of weird quirks around SVG,
because SVG is sort of
weird generally.
But it's promising.
And more importantly to me, it's
like the moment I saw the
clown car technique, which
has an awesome name.
I found myself thinking that
if I had access to this, I
would totally use it.
Because it's actually the
problem that I want to solve.
I want to make decisions about
the size of images and the
sources of images based on the
size of the images in the
page, not based on device width,
not based on viewport
width, not based on all these.
All those other things are
basically like wearing boxing
gloves and trying to
pick a pencil up
off the ground, right?
They're crude implements.
And so when I saw the clown car
technique, I'm not sure if
that actually will end up being
something that we, as
web designers, end up using.
But if it actually worked, I
don't think that the preparser
would have a choice.
I think web designers would
adopt it, and just move
forward, and say, figure
it out, browsers.
MIKE MAHEMOFF: Right, but that
would need the browsers to
support that format, really.
JASON GRIGSBY: Well, the format
works in a lot of ways--
nearly all modern browsers.
So that's not as much of an
issue as it is that, by doing
so, then you are in fact causing
the problems that John
was talking about, where the
images can't be requested
until much later.
JOHN MELLOR: So there's really
two things on the horizon that
I see as possible solutions
to this.
One is the client-end setter,
proposed by [INAUDIBLE], in
fact, where the browser would
provide information as to its
device pixel ratio and device
width with every HTP request.
And this would allow servers--
you would just specify a single
image in your markup,
and the server would send you an
appropriate image based on
your device using this
information without any device
databases and that kind
of [INAUDIBLE].
The other, and perhaps the
most promising but least
certain solution, is to use
a progressive image format
coupled with smarter browsers.
The idea is web developers
would save one ultra high
resolution image in a
progressive format, link to
that in their website, and then
the browser would only
load as many bytes
as it needs.
So initially, the browser would
start loading all the
images on a page in parallel,
because it knows it's going to
need at least some data
for all those images.
But then, based on the layout
size of the image, it'll then
decide when to stop downloading
images.
And maybe even if you pinch zoom
in, it'll load some more
images at that point.
So actually Simon Jordan has
got a prototype of this.
We're looking into it--
no promises yet.
MIKE MAHEMOFF: Cool, so we
should move onto WebRTC.
Well, I think Sam asked an
interesting question, which is
kind of the standard one.
Do you want to ask that
question again?
SAM: Yeah, just really, I see
WebRTC with mobile as the
natural home of WebRTC.
And I'm just wondering where
we can take this beyond the
kind of obvious application--
video chat apps and so on-- so
obviously directed at Justin.
JUSTIN UBERTI: So I think
there's a bunch of use cases
that people are starting to
realize where WebRTC is not
just making a phone call.
It's being used to kind of
take media that's on one
device and push it
onto another.
And one example is that you have
this very small screen
for a phone.
And wouldn't it be nice if you
could take that and shoot that
somewhere else?
Another thing is just that I
think a lot of carriers who
typically had very, very long
cycles to update any sort of
phone or device that's on their
network now see this
idea to be able to push in a web
app as a way to provide a
lot more value added services,
and do this in a way where it
prevents them from being kind
of just like a pipe.
And one of the things that's a
challenge to get from where we
are now to there is the fact
that right now, if you're a
web app, your traffic is
competing with, as I like to
say, cat videos.
You want to send voice traffic
or video traffic, and you're
just another packet
on the internet.
But carriers have the
ability to do
prioritization for traffic.
They do this already
for voice.
The voice calls that you make
are sent over a separate thing
than all the actual
3G and 4G data.
And to be able to expose that
QoS stuff to these voice
communication apps is what's
going to be able to make it on
a level playing field and allow
this web communication
to be the future of telephony
and communications.
MIKE MAHEMOFF: Sort of related
to that, the whole issue of
performance and bandwidth,
is also peer to peer.
And that's also potentially a
big part of WebRTC, right?
JUSTIN UBERTI: Sure, and I think
that you can think of
things like video
distribution.
One of the historical challenges
for over the top
video sites is that every time
you have a new subscriber,
that's an additional amount
of bandwidth you
need to send down.
And if you compare that to the
broadcast model where they put
up the towers, there's a fixed
cost, and then they have as
many subscribers as they want.
Moving to over the top video
is a lot more costly.
But if we think about--
for popular videos, if you could
then sort of get some of
the data from peers who are down
your street or something
like that, what could that
do to the actual data
distribution cost?
And WebRTC makes peer to
peer possible for just
a regular web app.
And I think you're going to
see some very interesting
transformations based on that.
MIKE MAHEMOFF: Yeah, I heard
someone from BitTorrent
talking about this as such a
tragedy that for each extra
user as a video user, you sort
of actually have to pay for
that bandwidth.
Whereas from someone like
BitTorrent's point of view, or
a peer to peer network, it's
actually a benefit for every
extra user.
It's the exact opposite.
So it is a real tragedy that
it doesn't happen.
And I think he was explaining
that it was to do with
analytics and content owners
wanting to be able to track
this sort of thing
and license it.
But I think those solutions are
also still possible with
WebRTC, aren't they?
JUSTIN UBERTI: Yeah, that's
definitely true.
I mean, I think that just
because you're not sending the
actual bytes of data down to
the client doesn't mean you
can't still collect analytics,
doesn't mean you can't still
collect play counts and
that sort of thing.
There still has to be some
master tracker to know where
you get your data from.
And so you can still keep all
those things in control, but
you'll send 1/1,000
of the data.
You don't need to actually
send a two
megabit 720p stream.
MIKE MAHEMOFF: So we've got
a question from Matt.
Is Matt here, Matt Lockier?
OK, you can read your
own question then.
MATT LOCKIER: OK, oh yeah,
it was just sort of--
oh, this is kind of unrelated
really to this section.
Did I ask another one?
Oh yeah, what's the status
of the audio API?
Also, will it kill my battery if
I'm analyzing for a really,
really long time, like if I'm
just listening and doing
distortion and trying to provide
cool things on mobile?
JUSTIN UBERTI: So we're trying
to get the Web Audio API lit
up on mobile.
And Ray, who's in the back of
the room, would be the person
who has the best
answer on that.
But one of the great things
about Web Audio is that the
heavy lifting of the actual
audio processing is done sort
of inside the browser, not
necessarily by JavaScript.
So it can be done very,
very efficiently.
And one of things I expect that
we'll see going forward
on mobile is that more and more
stuff will get offloaded
to hardware.
And so if there are cases where
we're seeing the stuff
really used for hotword
detection, or things like that
for speech, if it's killing
battery, we'll find some way
to make it efficient so that
your phone lasts all day.
MIKE MAHEMOFF: Also just
thinking about video a bit,
I've got a question here from
Rayhan, who's a friend of mine
in London, actually.
And he's basically
got a start-up to
do with real estate.
And he was wondering about how
he could use the camera and
actually sort of overlay things,
or do programmatic
transformations on top of it
as part of the stream that
gets recorded and played
back or uploaded.
JUSTIN UBERTI: Does he mean in
the user interface, or for
actually sort of decorating the
video as it's captured?
MIKE MAHEMOFF: Yeah, potentially
uploading that or
streaming that.
JUSTIN UBERTI: Right, so I
mentioned Web Audio is not
something that can be used to
actually post-process the
audio after it's captured.
And we're adding a similar
sort of API for video.
This is kind of all pre-standard
stuff, but
something where, within your
actual web application, you
can get the audio,
then process it.
If you wanted to do some sort
of special effect to it, put
on a silly hat or whatever,
you could then take that,
process it in JavaScript, and
then when it's sent out to
whatever the other peer is
that's going to then consume
it on the server, or maybe just
your friend on the other
side of the country, they'll
see the post-process video.
And you could also imagine
just generating a video
stream, too.
Perhaps it's not a traditional
sort of video chat example.
But maybe you want some way to
check in on some sort of
sensor network or something.
And the way it does so is
through some video output.
And you could create this actual
thing from some API.
MIKE MAHEMOFF: JavaScript.
JASON GRIGSBY: Just on the
subject of video, I've
actually got a request.
And that's to get the
adaptive streaming
stuff sorted out ASAP.
For people who are attempting to
do responsive design, from
a responsive design
perspective,
you'd like to have--
in the same way in which images
are a problem, source
video is an issue, right?
So you can provide
different codets.
But ideally, what you'd like
is, you'd like different
sources based on bit
rate, based on
the size of the screen.
It doesn't make sense for
somebody on a phone to
download a 1080p video.
And at the moment, we've got
HTTP live streaming on iOS.
But we don't yet have
implementations on the other
mobile devices so that we can
do the same sort of stuff.
And so I know that there's a
lot of work going into it.
I hope to see it on
devices soon.
Because if you end up in the
video space, it becomes very
problematic.
And you basically have to,
again, sort of make JavaScript
changes in order to
make it happen.
MIKE MAHEMOFF: OK, yeah, so then
that becomes a challenge
of you'd have to actually have
all those videos, right?
So again, you might have to do
something like Andre was
talking about of actually
generating those videos on the
fly, which could
be quite scary.
ANDRE BEHRENS: We're doing
more of that, too.
MIKE MAHEMOFF: Getting
into that, yeah.
JASON GRIGSBY: The days of save
to the web for video or
for images are over.
You need some way to automate
it on the server side.
MIKE MAHEMOFF: It leaves us
some interesting denial of
service possibilities,
doesn't it?
If you generate every pixel, or
every quality level, then
you have to generate a new
whole video for that.
JUSTIN UBERTI: You don't have
to generate every sort of
combination.
I think the matrix can still
be fairly sparse.
Because really, you see this
sort of linear progression of
bit rate goes up with
resolution.
And so if you watch Netflix,
what you'll see is that they
start sending you the lowest
quality thing while they're
still figuring out what
bandwidth you
can actually support.
And as you actually say, oh,
I can support 240p, 360p,
they'll keep ramping you up.
In Chrome, we do this through
the media source API, which is
the ability to sort of feed
in blocks of video.
And those blocks can keep
going up in size.
As each block comes in, the
actual entire video--
you don't have to get the
whole thing each time.
You just get each
little chunk.
And each chunk can be in
a different resolution.
MIKE MAHEMOFF: That makes
sense, actually--
sort of a little bit like
media query breakpoints.
You'd end up with.
So just last question
before we wrap up is
about Blink, actually.
Also Matt asked, what are
we going to see about
fragmentation?
And what are we going to see
from Blink in general?
This is for all the media types
we've been discussing.
JASON GRIGSBY: I believe
that Blink is--
no, I can't speak to this.
JOHN MELLOR: Blink's goal is to
work closer to [INAUDIBLE]
community.
And so we're going to try
and avoid [INAUDIBLE].
We're also trying to add more
testing about WPC, and so on.
And so we're tyring to make sure
that the implementations
of different browsers
are interoperable.
And so no particular media
has been on this.
It's kind of hard.
JUSTIN UBERTI: I think just
one of the interesting
questions is, what will
Blink mean for WebKit?
Because there are a
lot of Chromian
people working on WebKit.
And now that they're not there,
what will that mean for
the velocity of WebKit?
I don't know the
answer to that.
MIKE MAHEMOFF: Very much
an open question, so--
yeah, Bruce.
BRUCE: Can I ask a question?
MIKE MAHEMOFF: Yeah, go on--
one quick question, yeah.
BRUCE: About WebP--
hi, Bruce from Opera.
At Opera, we like WebP.
And we've used it for a long
time in the Presto
incarnation.
We've got something called Opera
Turbo to speed up the
desktop on slower networks.
And that transcodes images
on the fly to
WebP on slow networks.
That's still faster than
rendering the JPEG or whatever.
WebP is Google's format.
What plans are there to
popularize it and make it more
widespread?
I know that Firefox's initial
opposition seems to be softening.
I wonder if Microsoft's
opposition might soften now
that the WebM format
is clarified
vis-a-vis the MPEG LA.
But what are you going to do
to allow it to fall back on
browsers that don't support
WebP, for example?
JOHN MELLOR: It's
a good question.
Ilya, do you want to give them
more on this, perhaps.
ILYA: So part of the answer is,
we have a session on WebP
tomorrow where we're going
to cover exactly that.
But the short of it is, I
think we can make the
negotiation of WebP
much simpler.
So today, it's actually hard
to deploy WebP, right?
Either you have to use a
JavaScript fall back, either
you need to use a user agent
sniffing solution, and neither
one of those is good.
So we're actually fixing a bunch
of things in Chrome to
make that easier.
So you guys actually--
Opera has been advertising
image WebP in Accept.
We're lending that, and Chrome
now is in Canary.
That's going to fix
a lot of things.
It makes it very simple.
Just recently, we actually
had an integration
with an image CDN.
So CDN Connect--
cool service which does all
the imagery sizing and
everything on the fly.
It'll also detect that you're
advertising the right accept
header and serve the
appropriate image.
So that's one example.
Another example is something--
so I'm sure you guys have
heard that Facebook was
experimenting with WebP, right?
And they ran into a couple of
issues where users would save
the image, but then they
can't open it.
So we're fixing that as well.
Right now, we've registered
Chrome to
be the default viewer.
So at least you can
double click on it
and view the image.
Now, can you open
it in Photoshop?
You need a plug-in for that.
And this kind of thing
takes time.
One kind of crazy and
interesting idea that we're
also experimenting with is, what
if you had a safe Save
option, which is, when you right
click, and you click,
and you go Save As, we save,
I don't know, a JPEG or
something, which is transcoded
to some format that we know
that works?
And this is not specific
to WebP, right?
I hope that we have more image
formats in the future.
And if we can have the right
mechanisms to address these
issues, whether that's accept
header and a save and all the
rest, that'll help everybody.
BRUCE: Well, there's a level
four CSS module whose name
escapes me, because it's
typically snappily titled.
And instead of saying,
background image URL blah dot
PNG, you can say, background
image.
And then, it's image.
And then there, you can
give a list of images.
So you can have WebP,
then comma JPEG.
And that would make developers'
lives a lot easier
if that were turned
on in Blink.
ILYA: So that's really
interesting.
I actually wanted to ask--
I know that we're running
out of time.
But I want to ask you
guys about this.
So I think that solutions like
picture tag make the whole
situation much worse and
much more complicated.
Negotiating which format, or
which compression level, like
2x versus 1x--
you don't compress.
You don't have an index
HTML and index dot
html.gz on your server.
The server just does
that for you.
Negotiating 1x versus
2x versus 2.5x
should be the same thing.
Are we actually doing the
developers a favor by giving
them a picture tag, which is
15 lines long, because you
have a combinatorial explosion
of image formats times number,
or DPI resolutions times number
of art directions times
number whatever?
It just seems like
a step backwards.
ANDRE BEHRENS: I am strongly
in favor of not having to
think about things.
JASON GRIGSBY: Is it a favor?
No.
Part of the reason--
I look at this like whether
it's picture or SRC set or
whatever it is, continue
to advance those.
Because if people don't like
them, sooner or later,
somebody will be motivated
to come out
with something better.
And so the problem is
truly a problem.
And it's a problem for the
clients that we consult with.
It's a problem on the
projects we work on.
So we've got to continue to try
to find better solutions.
ILYA: So this is interesting.
Because when I talk to W3C and
other communities, they
actually tell me, hey, no, we
really want a markup solution.
We don't want to rely on
the server to do this.
JASON GRIGSBY: Sorry, I think
that it would be strange to
have a fundamental element of
HTML that required the server.
There's no precedent for that.
ILYA: But 1x and 2x is just
a compression setting.
You don't specify
a [INAUDIBLE]
link for--
go to this page, it's
compressed.
JASON GRIGSBY: Correct, yes--
I don't know, maybe.
MIKE MAHEMOFF: All right,
we've got to finish up.
So just in 30 seconds or less,
maybe you can just give out
one best practice that you'd
like to see more
developers be doing.
JUSTIN UBERTI: I'd like to see
people take advantage of the
peer to peer APIs that WebRTC
will be providing.
It's sort of at no cost, the
ability to get bulk data much
more cheaply.
JASON GRIGSBY: We know that
96% or 94% of responsive
designs are bloated crap.
And it would be really nice if
people built stuff mobile
first and performant when it
came to responsive design.
JOHN MELLOR: Be careful that you
always get poly-fills for
things like the picture
elements and so on.
Don't just assume they'll
perform well.
Actually measure that and cross
fingers for the best in
the future.
ANDRE BEHRENS: I think I would
say, notice there's a problem.
Open DevTools--
notice that not dealing with
it is a problem, and notice
that the solutions are a
problem, and make noise.
Because that's where solutions
come from.
MIKE MAHEMOFF: Get on
the Bug Tracker.
All right, thank you.
[APPLAUSE]